bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
ce matin alors on parle d'une reprise
épidémique est actuellement confirmé en
france
jean castex le premier ministre parle
d'une reprise durable est ce que vous
êtes inquiet face à la situation
aujourd'hui en france
il ya un kg et d'une certaine façon non
parce que quand même là l'immense
majorité de la population est vaccinée
donc protégé mais il n'en reste pas
moins qu'il ya une fraction de cette
population française qui est qu'il n'est
pas vaccinée pour diverses raisons dont
certaines certaines raisons sont le
refus pur et simple de la vaccination et
il y à une l'épidémie se développe chez
eux c'est-à-dire qu'il faut pas laisser
penser que le vaccin ne sert à rien
contraire il sert à protéger l'immense
majorité de la population et à atténuer
leurs bombes épidémique que l'on que
l'on constate actuellement il suffit de
regarder ce qui se passe dans des
territoires français qui n'ont pas la
même couverture vaccinale comme la
guyane où les antilles où là on assiste
à une vraie catastrophe telle que l est
et l été constatée en france au tout
début de tout début de la crise à avant
les vaccins donc le vaccin ça marche
mais tout le monde n'est pas vacciné et
donc le virus peut proliférer autant
qu'il a envie chez ces personnes non
vaccinées
l'association qui est donc à compliquer
vous venez de le dire pour les soignants
il y en a beaucoup qui ont jeté l'épongé
on l'a vu justement avec notre reportage
à cause de ce que vit 19 qui dure et
l'autre qui ne sont pas vaccinés
qu'elle
voilà quels dispositifs doivent mettre
en place le gouvernement pour justement
dire à ces personnes d'aller se faire
vacciner on sait que pour l'instant le
taux de vaccination stagne en france
nous aussi ces chiffres inquiétants
concernant l'épidémie
alors pour la population des soignantes
les choses sont claires il y a une
obligation vaccinale
etc sinon il y as impossibilité
d'exercer sans son métier donc les
choses sont assez claires et les refus
de vaccination sont assez marginaux
parce que les soignants sont des gens
responsables qui qui prend ça leur a au
risques qu'ils font courir aux patients
autour d'eux donc ça je crois que de ce
point de vue là la situation est
relativement claire par contre il ya un
autre problème mais qui n'a pas de
l'épisode coville qui datent de plus de
vingt ans qui est l'absence ou tout au
moins à une politique extrêmement
restrictives sur la formation médicale
la formation des médecins en france et
c'est tous les gouvernements depuis
libyen à 25 ans si ce n'est un petit peu
plus on leur parle là dedans pour que
cette population médicale soit
extrêmement restreinte et on en paye
maintenant
les résultats c'est à dire qu'elles
passent et médecins comme il était dit
dans votre sujet il n'y a pas assez de
médecins n'est plus assez de médecins
en exercice libéral qui permet de
traiter les personnes qui n'ont pas
besoin d'aller à l'hôpital donc ces
personnes là elles ont personnes n'ont
aucun recours donc il faut bien qu'elle
trouve une solution est la solution c d
urgence service public qui est ouvert en
permanence mais qui lui aussi souffre de
cette pénurie de médecins présents que
ce soit différent et donc on se retrouve
dans tout ce que vous êtes en train de
décrire c'est à dire des urgences qui
sont saturés par manque de deux médecins
ou par défaut de paraphes
l'ux21 du de patients et par la
possibilité d'évacuer d'urgence parce
que ans après les urgences il ya aussi
les manque de médecins et donc des lits
d'hospitalisation qui sent qu'ils sont
indisponibles donc tout ça fait un
mélange
extrêmement
détonnant qui as à son expression la
plus caricaturale maintenant avec la
crise commises mais c'était vraiment
quelque chose qui date de très très
nombreuses et la dernière question c'est
cavaniol mâcon va prendre la parole
mardi soir de nouvelles mesures
en tout cas l'exécutif réfléchit à la
mise en place de nouvelles mesures on
parle également de la 3e 12 la dose de
rappel pour l'instant il ne concerne que
les personnes âgées de plus de 65 ans et
ceux qui souffrent de maladies comme
orbite de comorbidité est ce que vous
pensez qu'il faudrait élargir les
critères pour cette troisième dose
je ne pense pas les données les données
scientifiques sont relativement
stabilisée de ce produit là on sait que
à partir d'un certain âge ou bien en
raison de comment me dit est la plus
extrême étant les l'immunodépression
donc dans cette population l'allée des
anticorps chute de façon significative
disons au delà de grossièrement après
après un temps un an après la dose à la
plus récente mais ça ne concerne que
cette population lolo la population
adulte standard j'allais dire
le rocher ne constate pas cette chute
donc il serait parfaitement inutile de
donner une troisième dose pour aux gens
qui n'ont pas besoin il faut au
contraire se concentrer sur ceux qui en
ont vraiment besoin
merci beaucoup en tout cas jean paul
installe d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes infectiologues
au chu de grenoble